this morning many americans and hundreds
of millions of people all across asia
are celebrating the lunar new year
beginning the year of the ox
in china the covet pandemic has changed
the traditional rush of people
who normally flood back to their home
towns to reunite with relatives for a
whole week
rami inocencio is in beijing for us
where many are trying to decide
do i stay or do i go
for sun she went the writer hopped a new
high-speed train from beijing with her
boyfriend 700 miles
south to her dad waiting at her hometown
station outside
shanghai and her mom at home
for chang yuen she stayed the musician
solo this chinese new year at her
family's four-bedroom home in beijing
sticking to government suggestions she
stays connected to her parents by video
since last april they've been in their
hometown
about 500 miles south her brother is in
boston
so how do you feel well i of course feel
really lonely and
kind of sad but chinese has a
term that lair feng chung that means the
future is long
and we will have more time it's okay
that we are not together
this time chinese new year is like
thanksgiving
christmas and western new year all
rolled into one that is just how
important this holiday is here at
beijing's central railway station
this place should be teaming with
thousands of people rushing to get home
this year not so much
inside workers spray disinfectant the
smell of bleach
rising from the floors as people scan
their tickets
then faces to board their trains people
returning to their ancestral homes in
the countryside
have to spend two weeks in quarantine
and pay for their own
covet tests people from low-risk areas
which is most of china
are urged to stay home as incentives
beijing has given out shopping coupons
and free cell data
and many cities are giving free money in
pay
to stay programs one shanghai company is
giving nearly
five hundred dollars to employees
now reunited with her parents wishes her
dad good fortune
but admits traveling is a risk if i'm
back
well my family has a risk of
being affected she did a rapid covet
test
and got a negative result and the
pressure from family
and thousands of years of tradition is
hard to deny
people should try their best to come
home said her mom
outside the forbidden city union says
she feels more tourists are in beijing
than in past
new years baba mama what's up i asked
her parents if they're sad she's not
coming home
her mom laughs and says no it's okay the
most important thing is to be safe
the past year of covet has pushed some
to keep tradition with family
and others to break them by staying away
this is the choice in china for the new
year
of the ox but despite
all those restrictions and incentives
hundreds of millions of chinese
are still traveling across china for
this lunar new year holiday
it's just so hard to keep family away
from family the good news
is that covid is mostly under control
here unlike in the united states
but if we see a surge in the coming few
weeks we'll know why
anthony creamy innocence in beijing
thank you looks very different than
mardi gras he does yeah